we live in a world of overused hyperbole
still it's hard to overstate the
phenomenon that is YouTube in just over
a decade it has risen from nothing to
seven billion hours of video watched
every month it is also the third most
visited site on the internet with 80
percent of viewers coming from outside
the United States it has more than 1.5
billion monthly users who are
entertained by 400 hours worth of video
uploaded every 60 seconds and on top of
all of that it's made a lot of people a
lot of money but have you ever stopped
and wondered how YouTube came about it's
a fascinating story and today you're
going to discover it all as we go behind
the scenes to bring you the real YouTube
story it all started with a chance
encounter in 1999 Eric Skaggs a local
entrepreneur was finishing up some work
on his website at the Eberly college of
business computer lab at Indiana
University in Pennsylvania his website
was called go get it now dot-com and was
an amalgamation of email search engine
and web hosting combines into a single
interface as he was about to leave the
building Skaggs saw a tall guy in a
baseball cap coming in they struck up a
conversation and Skaggs learned that
this guy was Chad Hurley
he was a graphics arts major who was
looking for an idea for a website the
idea Scaggs gave to Hurley was to
provide the inspiration for the YouTube
revolution he told him that in the
future television and computers would
become fully integrated furthermore
people would be able to use their cell
phones to create home videos and they
would want a platform to share them with
friends and family remember this was all
at a time when there were no cameras in
phones and TV in the Internet were very
different animals the idea of well it
was a little overwhelming for Hurley and
des stored it away for future reference
after graduating from Indiana University
with a fine arts degree he started
looking for employment in the exciting
new internet industry he picked up a
Wired magazine from his local grocery
store which featured the top ten
internet companies Hurley sat down and
redesigned those companies logos sending
them to the marketing departments of the
respective companies the one he did for
a company that you might have heard of
PayPal caught the eye of
founder Elon Musk and beforee newest
Hurley was hired as the company's first
graphic designer it was a PayPal that
Hurley was able to pick the brains of
the most brilliant techie nerds in the
industry the two smartest guys in the
room where Steve Chen and jawed Karim
Chen was born in Taiwan in 1978 with his
family moving to the United States when
he was eight years old he attended the
Illinois mathematics and Science Academy
where he proved to be a maths prodigy
his passion was Computer Engineering and
he went on to study computer science at
the University of Illinois he began
working for PayPal in 1999 a few months
before Hurley Jarrod Karim was born in
Merce burg Germany in 1979 living with
his family to the US when he was 13
from the started German was a computer
whiz in school he wrote computer
programs posting them on the internet
for free he also helped to set up the
school's email system just like Steve
Chen Karen went to the University of
Illinois where he studied computer
science after a number of internships
with a range of technology companies he
sought employment with PayPal in the
year 2000 where it was put to work on
designing the company's anti-fraud
security system early the graphic
designer Chen the engineer and Corinne
the systems guru soon found each other
and spent more and more time
brainstorming ideas for their own
startup for five years they kicked
around ideas while building up their
knowledge and experience of PayPal then
in January of 2005 Hurley was hosting a
dinner party at his home Jen was in
attendance and he began using a
camcorder to take some video off the
festivities the next day they wanted to
share the video with those who had been
in attendance the problem was that the
video files were way too big to send
over email and even though there were a
few photo sharing websites such as
Flickr and Shutterfly nothing existed
for the sharing of video online it was
at this point that the seed that had
been planted years before came to life
teaming up with Corrine they decided to
create a website to share videos the
idea was to use the video sharing
platform to create a dating site people
would post videos of themselves and they
could view these and respond if they
liked what they saw they called it
TuneIn hook up they launched this site
within days and then waited for the
users to come however well nothing
happens in an attempt to get some
content up on the site they placed ads
on Craigslist offering
to pay people to post videos still no
one was interested in and TuneIn hookup
became a huge flop the trio they were
disheartened but not dismayed shortly
after the demise of their first joint
venture jared was frustratingly
searching online for a video of Janet
Jackson's infamous 2004 Superbowl
halftime show wardrobe malfunction
because there was no user-friendly
platform for sharing video content he
wasn't able to satisfy his breast fetish
together with Hurley and Chen he decided
to do something about it
stripping away the lame dating concepts
if they were left with a video uploading
and sharing platform all they needed now
was a name for their website on favori
the 14th 2005 in a humble apartment
above a California pizza shop the trio
began building their new website
initially apparently in reference to
Janet Jackson's unwitting contribution
as they wanted to call it boob tube
realizing that that sounded too much
like a porn site they began playing
around with words that conveyed the idea
of personalized television talking back
to the days when the TV was called the
tube thanks to the cathode ray tube that
powered it one of the three no one knows
which one came up with YouTube it
sounded perfect they were short catchy
fun and it perfectly summed up what they
were about
when Hurley applied to register the
domain name the idea was to go with
YouTube with a view instead of y-o-u
however that domain was already taken
which forced him to proceed a tube with
the three-letter word you Hurley Chen
and Karim immediately set about writing
down the goals for YouTube at the top of
their list was ease of user experience
loading and watching videos had to be
super easy so that even the most
computer illiterate person could do it
they then divided up the workload
Chatterley was in charge of the look and
design of the site as well as tagging
and labeling loaded videos to make them
easier for viewers to find Steve Chen
was the engineer who made sure that the
site was running smoothly and that
videos played without lagging Jarrod
Corrine meanwhile used his programming
skills to get the site up and running
and looking great unlike the other two
Korean shows not to be an employee of
the company instead his role was that of
an informal advisor this allowed him to
focus on his graduate studies in
computer science at Stanford University
the first video ever uploaded onto
YouTube
was an 18 second clip long of Carim at
the San Diego Zoo entitled me at the zoo
you can still watch this historic clip
on the site where it has been seen by
more than 30 million people Hurley he
was put in charge of marketing he
started a competition where a different
youtube user was given the iPod nano
every day for eight weeks people earned
points by referring a friend or posting
a video the more points you gained the
greater your chances of winning the iPod
the promotion work since people began
flooding the site with video content
however this it created a problem so
much content was coming on board that
YouTube was running out of bandwidth
this made video playback excruciating ly
slow they were desperately in need of
more storage capacity which required
money but as of yet they weren't making
any fortunately on the basis of future
ad revenue forecasts they were able to
secure a 3.5 million dollar venture
capital loan in November of 2005 just a
month earlier a night promotional video
featuring Brazilian football star
Ronaldinho became the first youtube
curve to reach 1 million views by the
beginning of 2006 YouTube had grown to
more than 60 employees and the site had
more than 100 million views this was an
astounding level of growth considering
that just 12 months earlier they
literally couldn't pay people to post
videos on their website over the course
of its first year the nature of the
content being loaded onto YouTube it
evolved for the first few months the
majority of clips were of the home movie
variety but then more and more how to
videos began appearing with advice being
offered on how to do everything from
change the oil in your car to the proper
technique for doing a barbell squat as a
result YouTube was fast becoming the
go-to source for both entertainment and
information in June 2006 YouTube entered
a contract with NBC television this
marked a u-turn by NBC who had
previously forced YouTube to remove the
Saturday Night Live clip after it became
viral online now NBC agreed to pay
YouTube to place promotional clips of
their shows these were things such as
behind-the-scenes interviews and other
features
YouTube was by now attracting the
attention of the biggest players in the
web universe the site was wildly popular
with viral videos regularly appearing on
TV news broadcasts and even entire shows
being devoted to YouTube content the
sort of global reach that YouTube had
acquired was extremely inviting to the
biggest player of them all in October of
2006 the Google corporation purchased
YouTube for a staggering 1.65 billion
dollars the three tech nerds from PayPal
now have more money than they could
possibly spend in an entire lifetime
despite being independently wealthy
beyond measure Hurley and Chen stayed
with YouTube in fact they were thrilled
to be working with such a web giant as
Google they now had the freedom to focus
on adding new technology to the website
in an efforts to encourage people to
stay on the site for longer they added
extra features including suggestions of
follow-up videos that the viewer might
be interested in watching they also set
to work on making the YouTube experience
available through a greater range of
devices YouTube's mobile app lets people
watch videos on their cell phones and
people could now add YouTube clips to
their websites and their blogs in a move
that emphasized just how dominant
YouTube was in people's lives
Time magazine featured a YouTube screen
on the cover of its 2006 Person of the
Year issue in May 2007 the YouTube
Partner Program was launched this
allowed people who uploaded videos to
have a share in the ad revenue generated
by the advertising that was played
during their video now for the first
time everyday people were able to turn
their hobbies into successful online
businesses the program which is still in
operation today pays up loaders around
55 percent of the ad revenue over the
last decade this revenue source has paid
off big time for a relatively small
number of creators who are known as
youtubers who have created massive
followings and huge annual earnings they
have also been able to leverage their
popularity to obtain sponsorship deals
with merchandisers who are keen to get
their products in the videos some of
these youtubers have even landed movie
and TV roles as a result of their online
fame
2007 was also the year that YouTube
began impacting politics seven of the 13
candidates for the presidency of the
United States announced their campaigns
through YouTube this was followed by the
first YouTube presidential debate which
featured questions submitted by viewers
then in 2009 the capability was
introduced to upload and watch 3d videos
on YouTube well that same year the
staggering milestone of 1 billion views
per day was reached less than three
years later that number had mushroomed
to 4 billion the first video to reach 1
billion views was the unforgettable
Gangnam style by psy which reached the
milestone on December 21st 2012 in 2011
the new feature of live streaming was
added now major world events could be
watched in real-time making YouTube a
viable alternative to the television set
but YouTube was soon to prove that it
was more than just a recorder of
historical events January the 25th 2011
was a day of protest against the
government of President Mubarak in Cairo
Egypt throughout that day video of the
proclaimed Day of Rage began appearing
on YouTube this inspired and emboldened
thousands of Egyptian citizens who came
pouring out into the streets the
protests went on for 18 days and the
protesters were able to use YouTube
along with Facebook and Twitter to
galvanize the support that would
eventually lead to change Mubarak's
regime reacted to the skillful use of
the Internet on the part of its
detractors by imposing a sweeping
crackdown of the Internet this only
further enraged the protesters
eventually forcing Mubarak to step down
and democratic elections to be held for
the first time in decades in 2011 there
was also a major overhaul of the
websites look the video channels were
displayed in a central column and the
YouTube logo was updated the Google
Chrome browser was also integrated so
that viewers could watch YouTube
directly through Google Plus two years
after that YouTube began offering paid
subscriptions for a monthly feed this
service allowed subscribers do you watch
longer ad free videos as well as movies
so what are the founders of YouTube up
to now well in October of 2010 Chad
Hurley stepped down the CEO of YouTube
handing over the reins to salaka Munger
he committed to staying on as an adviser
to the company Steve Chen left the
company at about the same time and the
two began working together on a new
venture a vos systems their headline
product was an iPhone app called mixbit
which allows users to shoot edit and
share video clips Averill systems has
acquired a number of other companies
including delicious and tap 11 Chad
Hurley was also a major sponsor of the
US f1 Formula One racing team he is also
a part owner of the NBA team the Golden
State Warriors and the MLS Los Angeles
Football Club in 2014 after 15 years of
collaboration Chen and Hurley parted
company Chad took over full control of
mix that while Chen went over to Google
Ventures as an entrepreneur in residence
making it clear that there was no
animosity in the parting Chen explains
actually it was a very personal and
difficult decision to make but with the
decision to turn a vaasam to mix this it
became pretty clear mix there was Chad's
idea before he started Avis and even at
YouTube and if I feel driven to work on
other projects then I'm just getting in
the way of mixed it and the team
Jared Currin completed his graduate
studies at the University of Illinois
emerging with a master's degree in
computer science of the three founders
he received the lowest portion of stock
however this was still enough for him to
earn around 64 million dollars from the
sale to Google in 2008 he launched
university ventures which provides
mentorship expertise and contacts for
college students who want to take
innovative projects to the next level
Krim was also one of the first investors
in Airbnb in 2009 towards the end of
Krim hit the headlines when he objected
along with many other YouTube users to
Google's requirement that commenting on
YouTube videos only be done through a
Google+ account he showed his
displeasure by changing the description
on his iconic near the zoo video to read
I cannot comment here anymore since I
don't want a Google+ account as a result
of Karen's stance backed up by a 240,000
signature petition Google dropped its
requirements that commenters must use
their Google+ products
it is truly mind-blowing to contemplate
just how big YouTube will become the
next few years new features are
constantly being rolled out to enhance
the viewer experience YouTube has
already replaced TV as the main source
of entertainment information for many
people according to Google executive
chairman Eric Schmidt the exponential
growth of YouTube will bring it six or
seven billion unique visitors per month
with that growth largely being driven
from the developing world YouTube has
become a launching pad for a growing
number of breakout stars including
Justin Bieber and Greyson Chance there
have even been a number of TV shows that
began life as YouTube's kits including
broad city and workaholics YouTube is
the most public place in the world
accessible from the privacy of our own
bedrooms it has created unprecedented
opportunities for learning entertaining
and earning a living but just like
anything YouTube it can be abused for
one thing it can be mind numbing the
addictive you might sit down to watch a
three-minute clip and three hours later
you're still slouched in front of the
computer watching cats playing piano or
hopefully you know watching one of our
videos and well speaking of by graphics
videos please do not forget to subscribe
we put out brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday now obviously this video
was a bit different it's our first
biography of a company please let us
know what you think of it in the
comments below also give it a like if
you did like it suggestions for
companies that you might be interested
in us doing again leave those in the
comments and as always thank you for
watching